oh you [ __ ] [ __ ] huh oh but if
it's for sport like yeah i'm like [ __ ]
now i feel back in the corner [ __ ]
i answered too quick
wouldn't it be way worse if you were
just like oh yeah i'll beat the [ __ ] out
of a chick for free
wouldn't that be way worse i can't
believe you have a [ __ ] price tag on
it
dude
alex freestyle about nick's stupid face
here we go yo my man's nick what why you
look like that why you breathe like that
what why you think like that yeah you
need a change huh you need some milk huh
you need a orange what go work on
yourself
bars those are very like not very
specific but it's still hurt
the more factual ones kind of hurt i was
like i was like these are all true you
gotta call them stupid you need to drink
milk talk about where he came from i do
need to drink my okay it's more vitamin
d bro you need a focus huh you haven't
started your website yeah
you said you wanna do an online program
but you never did it yet huh
daddy's up in another country what
just just normal no no we're like the
deepest [ __ ]
[Laughter]
shout out to my dad if you're listening
pops get the [ __ ] out of here bro yeah
taiwan yes
he probably is listening to this and
he's very sad right now nah he gets it
he knows oh he gets it i don't know some
place
yeah you know you're placing another
country have you guys have you been to
taiwan yet or not oh i've been to taiwan
dude dude food is hella fire i watch
david's vlogs and i feel like i've been
just taiwan oh let me tell you something
though that video was really hard to
shoot that video was really cool those
videos that video series you did very
cool yeah yeah that could have been some
online gilbert liked it because right
when i got my camera gilbert's like all
right whatever you need to do just get
whatever
david had in this video so our videos
look like this
yeah i carried like literally 40 pounds
of equipment with me everywhere i went
and i shot like that for the so we were
there for about two weeks i shot i i
shot all that content within four days
wow but those four days i don't remember
any of it because i only shot it was
shooting through the lens so what i
remember is the video that i shot yeah
there's a theme with david here
but it's like when he does something
he
forgets about all of it like you just
for he just does you don't remember
things because i think you're just so
wrapped up but no that's true because i
just recently went to disneyland like a
week like last weekend or whatever and i
brought my camera and maybe honestly
like i got some cool pictures but i only
took a little bit because like maybe an
hour and i was like man i kind of want
to just enjoy this like you know i don't
want to like because it does become work
right well yeah but then it's just like
you don't you're not focusing on what
you're doing you're focusing like all
right let me take pictures and videos
yeah when i was when we were that was
the biggest thing when we all started
vlogging on youtube years ago right
every event that we did and everything
that we were doing was based on what we
could shoot so when we would go on
vacation it's like oh what are we going
to shoot does you know there was a point
to where i remember bart was this
[ __ ] we're having dinner and he
goes oh wait can you can you say that
joke again so i can record it and then
literally look i was like [ __ ] you dude
no
are you insane but it started to become
like that where everybody was just
whipping out their camera which i'm
actually perfectly fine with it's just
cut you just have to read the room a
little bit yeah and then kind of know
what's going on if we're having fun and
we just started dinner yeah let's record
well in the middle of stuff we're having
a great conversation and you're trying
to stop the conversation so we could
redo a joke from the camera now we have
a problem that's pretty cool though yeah
okay
i'm all for that
but i felt that like really because when
if you ever put up content you [ __ ]
losers
your sister in florida
[Applause]
that pug that you guys have don't love
you
my boy baxter getting old bro
oh man he's going to die soon now
you think about
have you ever had a dog die on you yeah
i did i had a golden retriever die on me
when i was her name was coco she was
like the childhood dog coco i remember
that that's the hardest i've ever cried
in my life i wasn't like i was i think i
was in like fourth grade bro how old was
the dog
she was like 13. oh it was pretty cool
unfortunately i've lost like
nine or ten minutes i never get an
animal bro low key honestly
once once my dog's passing away i don't
know if i'll be like emotionally ready
to get another dog the thing for us is
we got a lot i think we got a lot of
dogs at the same time so like and
because you know my parents were never
together so i had two dogs at my dad's
house i had two dogs at my mom's house
uh but then we had put like one of the
dogs had puppies so then like you know
we kept some we gave some to friends and
then my brother kept one so we just had
dogs but like all the boston terriers
over this time like the last one
literally just passed away last week my
brother put her down because she was
like
15 and a half but she had some sort of
like disease where like her fur started
coming off and [ __ ] and then my
grandma's dog who was part of her litter
uh passed away like two months before
that and then the parents of those dogs
passed away just from old age oh it's
been old days i thought you meant these
thoughts just be dying dude no but we
didn't we had two yeah we had two pass
away from like horrible things because
one of them's name was seiko
he was like my absolute favorite watch
yeah yeah and uh big fans of the watch
yeah big fans of watch he was an
american bulldog full blood american
bulldog huge dog but he loved me i was
the only one that could walk him off lee
she slept in my room every single day so
he's my like my baby right and then so i
decided to come out here to visit some
family friends for a while
or to visit them a week before we were
coming out here for a week so i was just
they were just like oh just come out
it's summer who cares just stay or two
weeks but i that week i was supposed to
be watching that dog because my brothers
and [ __ ] were out of town somewhere else
and then my stepdads my daughters were
out of town so that was my up like my
job but my mom's like no just go it's
okay i'll watch him i'll watch him it's
cool and remember this arizona in the
summer so it's [ __ ] hot and this is
okay we should be outside this is like
june where it's like [ __ ] blazing hot
um my mom like i'm so i get to
california i'm here for like four days
my mom calls me and she's like hey what
are you doing i was like um we're just
doing something like fun
what are you doing yeah and then she was
like all right well stop because i have
to tell you something right and then she
told me that seiko died and she told me
that she got home she put him outside
she ran upstairs used the restroom was
upstairs for about 10 minutes
went outside and he was just laying
there dead oh so it's like she we we
don't know ever what happened he either
had a heat stroke or something like that
you know but that one was bad because
for me i was like i was supposed to be
there this week watching him and
and that was not 10 minutes your mom
left that outside for a hell of a little
while but she's both
yeah i just left them out there for
about two and a half seconds
like you know
yeah i'm sure
you know for her it was like you know as
a freak accident she probably was just
like it was only like 10 minutes lata
but
he was a big boy like he was big you
know always slobber and [ __ ] so even if
it was like 30 minutes that's still too
long for him right it's just too hot the
so that one was hard for me because i am
i felt guilty i was like man i was
supposed to be here so i remember when i
got home i went outside to bury him
outside and i just stayed outside for
like three hours crying and but the
worst one not your fault yeah i know
the worst one
was when i moved here we had these
little [ __ ] um
they're called like miniature pitbulls
so they have like a the body of like a
datsun but they have like the head of a
big pit and [ __ ] right and her name was
lucy she was the sweetest dog and we
were there barbecuing
and she was she got outside
and um so my mom was like hey lucy got
out and we weren't tripping because like
she doesn't run away or anything she
goes outside but we both went out front
to go get her and she ran across the
street because she was like like i was
about to say talking to another doctor
yeah but she was like sniffing it up
what's up she was sleeping she was
sniffing at another dog right and like
we were like wave at the lady she was
like oh she's sweet she's like yeah
she's cool like we're having a
conversation and they're just sitting
there sniffing and this is in temple
city on the main street so i'm like all
right cool so i just start stepping out
to walk over there and like i'm like
halfway in the street and i stop because
the car's coming so i'm waiting and as
i'm waiting i look at lucy she just
looks at me
and goes to run towards me and literally
is boom riding in front of me and i just
like turn around i'm like [ __ ]
and then my mom's just screaming like
right and like you see we see lucy
rolling across the street and then like
i'm like oh i look at her i'm just like
oh man and then she gets up and runs i'm
like oh [ __ ] so i like chase after her
and she ran right next to her next door
neighbor's house and laid on there and
she was just panting right but just
bleeding out of her mouth and just
internal organs dude pooping and peeing
just non-stop poo and pee
and like i was like my mom's like pick
her up and i'm like i don't wanna i
don't wanna touch her like i don't wanna
hurt or anything so eventually get in
the car but yeah everything inside of
her was completely broken and they were
like we can try to use surgery but there
was like there is a
99.9 chance that it's not successful so
we we had to put her down but that one
was the worst one did you grab the
doctor and say you [ __ ] save him
we felt so bad though because actually
literally like right in front of us like
i was like so you can get a dog soon or
what i want to bro
i suggest not yeah bro what are these
stories man hey man baxter though
knocking on that heaven's door he is bro
but he had a good life bro
yeah he had a good life and it's like it
is at that point where you have to kind
of like make peace with it a little bit
like slowly you better get your cries
out now bro i i hey last week bro your
boy was like because he was like running
around and he was just super excited to
play with me he's like 4 13 now and he
threw out his back a little bit bro he
started coughing because he just was
like so tired and too excited and i was
like oh my god are you okay and i was
like yeah i was like kind of after that
i was like kind of shook bro hey chill
come here yeah bro i don't try trying to
hold him and [ __ ] but he's been he's
he's a good dog but let's talk about
something else less depressing bro
because i'm sure your [ __ ] podcast
listeners don't talk about dead dogs yo
your dog is gonna die
this is actually why we have you here
next 13 years hey bro
they've never loved a baxter dies this
week i'm beating all your ass i'm coming
for all you guys
i'm moving to arizona
yeah
i'll balance it out i'll kill another
dog out there
podcast out there
but no i feel the same way because i was
just in arizona recently and we have a
dog named katie um my dad got her like a
year before i moved out here so she's
about nine i think or eight
eight and a half and she's uh but she's
a big dog right and their life doesn't
last as long as these small dogs but
last time i got this she has arthritis
in both legs so she like walks
like weird and [ __ ] but i'm looking at
him like damn katie's getting old that's
the thing that people don't know dude
dogs dogs die bro i've had uh yeah i've
had a couple dogs die man and guess what
your boy didn't shed a single [ __ ]
teeth yeah because you're a heartless
little no i was like it's time to go out
like a g yeah
and pour it off at home and then i
poured a 40 on her real quick and i said
i choked him out real quick just like
hey
yeah and they just went in piece like
that someone called the cops on this
full girl
[Laughter]
at least you know at least on me i'm
crazy when you get older though you it
it comes a little easier because you
know what comes with it right i'm lying
i cried my eyes out yeah i had a cocker
spaniel this whole name was victor
mexican as [ __ ]
straight up hey victor hurry up and he's
like oh sorry
every time they talked about their dog
all of a sudden they turned so mexican
hurry up man
yeah he passed away i think he was 14
and a half years old
english cocker spaniel rest in peace a
stupid [ __ ] all right but i had to take
him over to to get uh to get you know
the lethal shot yeah but then i didn't
want to watch him watch them do it so i
just dropped them off i said my goodbyes
and i was just like chilling i'm like
you know that wasn't so bad and then a
friend calls me and i'm as i'm driving
and she goes oh did you drop your dog
off today was it hard i was like
i'm gonna call you back
you'll be hella fine until like someone
calls you and you just want to talk
about it i'll show you both quite right
your boys get shaky like yeah
yeah you know what's going it was going
to be crazy you know what the hardest
part for you is going to be is when
you're you're fine everything's cool and
you forget that your dog passed away and
then something reminds you of the dog
then all of a sudden you feel the
problem i'm about to cry right now but
i'm about to beat all your asses if
you're trying to make me cry
[ __ ] this guy needs therapy
a little emotional volatile
toxic masculinity it is weird though
it's like only the dogs right because
we've had some cats
that passed away and i'm just like i did
yeah hey you know why though cause cat
like certain cats they just don't [ __ ]
with you that much oh you want to share
some [ __ ] though you know like cats will
actually when they know that they're
going to die they'll hide away you won't
be able to find them because they want
to die away from you
that's because they hate you bro that's
like i want this [ __ ] near me
when i die let me die peacefully don't
you look at me when i'm dying that's
kind of crazy how like respectful cats
are yeah they die away from you which is
kind of which is kind of [ __ ] nuts so
if you have an old cat and you can't
find that cat it's because it went away
to die but like a lizard i had a lizard
that it was a pet and he died and i was
just like all right cool what do i do
with this cake
but dogs are different i was chilling in
my in the living room dogs are the best
and then i heard leaves just kind of
scrape over the the concrete and i
thought it was a dog running up to me
and i turned around i remember i was
like oh
dude i started crying my eyes out yeah
and then my dad came up to me and he was
like what a [ __ ]
he's like bro victor was old yeah chill
my dad's heart was dead
he's calling me a [ __ ] bro
what's crazy to me is how people get
dogs and they just like go and take them
to the parks and dip out and [ __ ] this
podcast is brought to you by quip my
friends what if i told you my friends
that you can get rewarded for brushing
your teeth sounds crazy but it's not
because with quip smart electric
toothbrush you can get rewards just for
the great and good habit of brushing
your teeth and i swear by this if you
use the tech that you have right now to
develop great habits it makes your life
better and look you're going to brush
your teeth anyways but do it with
equipment get rewarded gift cards
discounts and free products from quick
partners in addition to brush heads quip
also delivers fresh floss toothpaste
mouthwash and gum refills every three
months from five dollars shipping is
free so you can save money and skip the
hustle and bustle of in-store shopping i
hate in-store shopping start getting
rewards for brushing your teeth today go
to quick.com genius right now to save
ten dollars on a quip smart electric
toothbrush that's ten dollars off a
smart electric toothbrush at get quip
dot com slash genius spelled
g-e-t-q-u-i-p dot com genius quip the
good habits company how do you guys do
that like
well they just like leave them yeah they
just
[ __ ] leave them and [ __ ] i'm like oh
you like abandoned them yeah oh yeah
like i don't know how they think well
those people are just terrible people
and that's all it is well you know what
happened during pandemic right everybody
got a bunch of [ __ ] dogs because they
thought it was a cool idea and when
everybody had to start going back to
work because the you know country
started opening up again yeah the pounds
are [ __ ] impacted with all these
[ __ ] yeah bro people not everyone
should have a dog bro having a dog is
like having a little infant for the rest
of your life yeah
13 years of it you've got to clean up
them you have to clean up their [ __ ]
they're pissed they're poo everything
yeah and on top of that too when you
travel they didn't think about that yeah
well now i'm traveling i have to think
about who can come here and take care of
this dog who can babysit this dog it's a
whole [ __ ] i love dog sitting bro me
too i'm all about it all right you could
babysit my dog next time i'm out of town
dude usually usually when i help you i
will yeah i will me and alex both will
yeah perfect that dog is super cute i
used to walk dogs and like when i would
house it the households always had dogs
i [ __ ] love that [ __ ] bro well
riley's easy she just pees and poos on a
on a grass pad and then it's next to the
toilet so you just pick up the poop i
mean riley barely liked me last time i
was here so riley's starting to warm up
i think she just takes longer it just
takes a while yeah yeah she has to see
it's like frequencies right yeah she has
to see you a couple times riley don't
really like salvadorians though just
just off top
she liked tiff
did she though tiff is salvadorian right
yeah my wife yeah yeah
[ __ ]
did she leave did she meet too yeah at
the [ __ ] a softer thing
yeah oh yeah that's true but there was a
baby around that's different what does
that mean
that [ __ ] was bomb
i [ __ ] went i looked for david for an
hour and i was like all right i'm gonna
leave and then i saw david right at the
end i was like all right cool i want to
tell that story so bad now but i can't
yeah cuz i'm so scared what happened
we'll tell you all fair
yeah yeah okay but let's just say like
i can't say it on this podcast because
my life would literally be in [ __ ]
danger if i did like i'm [ __ ] if i
start telling the story that's how crazy
this situation was but no what are you
guys up to no but that flavor
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was so [ __ ] good dude we
had a strawberry hibiscus
with a lemon cake batter vanilla lemon
cake batter soft serve swirled together
with
uh crumbs or
pistachio uh with a crumble on top i
forgot oh almond crumble on top
with kaffir lime leaf dust and uh
mascarpone cheese on the bottom tasted
just like a strawberry good humor bar
yeah and the thing about like the
flavors that you did for this drop i
felt like there was more you too yeah it
was more like okay you could do what we
want yeah yeah yeah like it's this is
not just like
asian people like these flavors yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know but that [ __ ]
was bombed though no i ate that [ __ ] and
i was like damn i feel like it's
different i'm about to look too fat if i
go get another one because i got the
sundae and [ __ ] but i was like
[ __ ] that [ __ ] well pretty tasty i got
the sorbet and the slender that she was
fired this was an idiot i told him to
get the [ __ ] sundae hey there was no
words i went up and i was like i'm gonna
get the sorbet and then after i come out
this is how david he's like what the
[ __ ] is wrong with you you stupid
[ __ ] [ __ ] why didn't you get the
sundae you piece of [ __ ] gaslighting
but he did post a story saying get the
sundance so
this is right here read stories bro
i just tap tap tap tap tap and i'm like
you know what that's that's the [ __ ]
thing beast from [ __ ] beauty and the
beast i can't read yeah [ __ ]
literally bro okay pick it dog i don't
know i can't read that are you guys
still just doing gonna do pop-ups so do
you have uh
we're planning to as of right now we're
thinking about opening up a sausage
truck next year oh
your boy is going to be uh reducing the
amount of podcasts next year is going to
be once a week
uh it's still going to be really fun i
just got it i just got so much [ __ ] on
my plate uh it's just it's already hard
to do twice a week as it is right now
yeah and so we're just going to be
working on the software stuff man but my
man i heard you on the market right now
ladies oh i heard my man my man heart's
open
he took a big deep breath like off nah
i'm i'm i'm chilling for a little while
that's what until a fine ass sich come
through
my my focus right now is [ __ ] we out
here
grinding and that's it okay well while
you grind
your grinder
why are we grinding what if a girl come
up she goes i love me out here mma yeah
i'd be like cool
because we have literally zero female
listeners i know the only female
listener we have killed herself
what is this she's dead
yeah yeah it's probably tiff and
my ex and that's it
yeah did you guys have zero female
listeners i'm pretty sure we got zero i
think i think a genius brain is about 40
women 60 yeah you know we should check
that i'm pretty sure we have very well
because we did a live stream once and we
had remember that girl came in and she
was talking and
i forget but guilt member gilbert was
like going back and forth with her that
was once i know but i i actually am
amazing it's a very like female
heavy sport sexist dude yeah i know
plenty of women who like it megan fox
yeah megan yeah of course megan fox cool
all right what else meghan or levy
that's right she doesn't consume the
media she don't consume the mma yeah i
mean it's mostly male right would you
would you ever okay i'm gonna put it to
you guys right now all right
there's about ten thousand dollars that
you can make and you have to fight a
woman but she weighs 30 pounds heavier
than you you take this fight yes or no
hundred percent yeah yeah you would just
beat women while you you [ __ ]
[ __ ] huh oh but if it's for sport
like yeah i'm like [ __ ] now i feel back
in the corner
wouldn't it be way worse if you were
just like oh yeah i'll beat the [ __ ] out
of a chick for free
wouldn't that be way worse i can't
believe you have a [ __ ] price tag on
it
brown out here beating up chicks for
free oh that's old now put it on the r b
king huh
or the prince
okay look
i was talking to a friend and he's a
very funny guy we all know but i'm not
going to say his name just for other
reasons but i was telling him i was like
hey you hear chris brown chris brown
beat up another chick and he looked at
me and goes you know if you beat up
rihanna you're probably willing to beat
up any girl and i was like wow i never
well chris brown beat up somebody else
again like recently really i thought you
should i thought you guys knew about
that
how come you keep how come you won't
stop hitting women exactly bro what's
going on yes it has to be right like you
have to be nah this dude just crazy he
just like sees a girl's face he goes
this [ __ ] dude
there's ten thousand dollars we beat her
up guys like guys like that are people
that haven't had their ass be yet yeah
you know because like it's like
he he's just get he has like some sort
of mental thing where he's so cocky like
growing up
needs to be listening
this needs to be listening to [ __ ]
mean that's it it's like to me in my
head it's like okay so you've never had
your ass be or you had your ass be way
too much and then the only person you
can beat up is a female that won't be
able to defend themselves against you
don't just be smacking people up like
that what the hell is wrong with them
man look it up right now just like just
make r b music and [ __ ] [ __ ] bro bro
you and you're actually good at making
music yeah man chill always banger after
banger after banger what the [ __ ] he has
that one time he's like bang her banging
her oh
they keep saying bang her okay
i got it okay i'll fight her that's a
banger baby i got you
[Music]
okay r b star 32 is alleged to have
struck the woman on friday 18th of june
san fernando valley hey it was friday
the 18th though man you don't you know
what happens on friday 18th spooky [ __ ]
yeah
she grant she was granted a five-year
restraining order against him in 2017.
if you get a five-year
restraining order against a guy who
happens to be a pop star who's very
successful but why is that that means
there's some marriage right because
you're only five years though but
usually it just continues yeah well
usually it's only like a year no
but like they're like actually after you
go beat him up again yeah like oh yeah
y'all could resume yeah
that's all good he's just outside our
house with a [ __ ] watch
like this too he's like all right
he's like just two more hours
[ __ ] damn like your wrists are
like
that tina ortiz hand he's like all right
you see those kids when they're about to
hit you because they better
usually it's like a term right it's
agreed upon term from the judge
depending on the severity of the issue
i'm pretty sure damn that's that's
that's weird crazy to me like five years
if a guy if a guy's beating up a girl
and she wants a restraining order of him
forever the judge be like okay but only
for five years i'd be like whoa cuz i
think the thought process is after a
year that would be all right it's like
it was like a tijuana court or some [ __ ]
but but
but also when a guy beats up a girl
that's a very different yeah i honestly
i think that's some sort of mental
sickness or something like that it has
to be yeah because he definitely grew up
in an abusive home yeah i think i read
somewhere that like his he's watched his
like father like beat his mother or
something like that that sucks because
they can either make you so extreme the
opposite way or you can end up being
exactly like them well that's the thing
too it's like i'm not saying that to
excuse his behavior but because i know a
lot of people now
don't take like these like past [ __ ]
that happens to them and they try to
make it as an excuse as if it's gonna
work for them for the whole their whole
life yeah eventually people just stop
giving a [ __ ] and you're just a shitty
ass [ __ ] person exactly so fix it
[ __ ] because there's other people that
don't do that exactly they have been
through the same things maybe even worse
and still doesn't do it because empathy
only goes a certain way it's like i can
be empathetic up to a certain point yeah
but you can't keep socking my eyes yeah
i'm like oh you grew up in a [ __ ]
abusive house okay i understand empathy
yeah to me that's just wild like for to
think about like a guy you just said you
would do it for 10 g's
i answered that [ __ ] way too quick
i'm gonna put down a record i heard 10k
your boy kind of went wow
that changed my life oh yeah this make
believe scenario automatically means
you're a piece of [ __ ] alex i'm sorry
because i said no but you you didn't say
well no you you said no after i said yes
and david was like you beat up a girl
and they're like yeah no
no i wouldn't do it on the record i
think if we go back and play i never
said no i said yes yeah i think i think
you did say yes dude i did oh 100 said
yes i just never said that this is crazy
that that reminds me did you guys see
the story but i guess there was like
this 22 year old girl that went missing
randomly and then they just found that
now the boyfriends in
tiff just sent me the [ __ ] thing yeah
now the brian landry yeah missing who's
that the guy guy's fiance
of missing 22 year old gabby patito has
also gone missing wow so the girl
has gone missing and then so was the guy
so the guy probably dipped yeah because
so the girl went missing i just saw all
this [ __ ] so the girl went missing and
then i guess after a little bit the the
boyfriend was in questioning now he was
the prime suspect and they just released
footage of um cops getting called on
them like they were out camping or some
[ __ ] like that and the cops got called
because it was like some domestic [ __ ]
and they got called out and it was a
thing but i guess now that that guy's
missing now too yeah
they just reported this two hours ago
damn wait so wait so this is a missing
person's report yeah the the woman was
missing the fiancee right and then
now who reported her missing
uh i have no idea i don't know i'm the
family dude
yeah uh then the fbi wants to look for
her and then
now he's nowhere to be found but he was
but he became the suspect there oh he's
always like the husband is always going
to be this is always going to be the
suspect yeah it's just like did you guys
ever watch that um
the documentary on netflix the killer
next door yes
yeah it was the one that was the husband
yeah the whole one with the oil rig he
dropped the base yeah but that that [ __ ]
was crazy bro and what's crazy is that
the neighbor knew the whole time the
name of the beginning the neighbor
called that [ __ ] because they're in
there watching this footage and the guy
leaves he's like hey he's not acting
right yeah he's like he never talks this
much he's like now this guy won't shut
the [ __ ] up yeah he goes let me surmise
about what's going on here and yeah they
did a recap we did a recap on jk news
because the story came up there was like
there was a lady who was like a
psychologist or something
and she was trying to say that this guy
his name was chris something or whatever
the [ __ ] yeah she was like going out
there saying oh i'm an advocate for him
he didn't do it there's no [ __ ] way
and like they're kind of in a
relationship and all these women are
trying to just send them [ __ ] letters
like they [ __ ] love this guy i don't
know i don't know even though he
admitted to doing it i don't know what
the [ __ ] it is about women that find a
guy who killed their whole family hello
my friends let's keep this podcast going
and sponsored by our lovely sponsor
current my friends if you are sick of
the current banking system that you have
with all their stupid fees long lines
and clunky ass apps then current will be
the one for you i'm right there with you
man technology is improving at a rapid
rate and i want my banking to be just as
easy streamline and advanced as
everything else it's all about
accessibility and why should we always
get surprised by weird fees when all i
want is flexibility freedom and faster
access to our damn money current is a
tech company that lets you manage your
money on your phone current believes
banking should be more accessible and
affordable no surprises and no minimum
balances which honestly is how it should
always be for a limited time we
partnered with current to give 500 away
that's right current is going to give
away a hundred dollars to five listeners
of our show all you have to do is
download the current app and enter our
code brain during sign up for a chance
to win remember that's brain during sign
up winners will be awarded soon so don't
wait download the current app sign up in
less than two minutes and enter code
brain for a chance to win visit
current.com
brain for full terms and conditions they
just are immediately like attracted to
like i don't know there's a certain type
of person out there who's the really
handsome serial killer okay we just
watched the whole [ __ ] thing we
talked about jk news today we were
talking about uh ted bundy yeah the
girls love dog that guy is one of the
creepiest [ __ ] i've ever seen
in my life obviously with the context of
me knowing that he killed a bunch of
people yeah charming as [ __ ] though huh
when he would talk he in the courtroom
he did his own case nick's like he kind
of made me start acting like
i was like my shirt was coming off bro
no they also with the night stalker too
but richard ramirez he was he wasn't he
was bashing crazy yeah
but girls i remember my mom told me this
story because they all lived out here
right because he killed people in this
[ __ ] melee arcadia yeah in this
neighborhood he [ __ ] killed people
right and it's just like i'm like in
this house that we're in he killed
people
it was like what the [ __ ]
no but um my mom even told me she's like
i remember during that time because they
all lived out here she's like we were
terrified to go out he's like we were
girls and she you know and she was like
um but she's like i remember being so
mad because
she was like there was girls at like our
school and you'd go out and girls like
this and girls wanted him so bad when he
was on trial she's like i just remember
being so mad she's like man i can't even
find a [ __ ] boyfriend and all these
all these girls want to go and [ __ ]
be with richard ramirez
that's it's crazy to think about crazy
[ __ ] i'll tell you man girls
just like guys with a little bit of
mystery you know what they want they're
trying to fix him yeah if he had this
[ __ ] he would never he would never
that's true the only thing he's
murdering is my gut
but when you watch that did you guys
watch that documentary uh that's that
bunny or the nice the richard ramirez
one i i was like i don't know if i want
to watch it bro you should it's really
good but there is one so [ __ ] up scene
where this girl's this little girl her
mom uh
i think it was there was two little
girls because he also raped little girls
too right oh my god um and so one of
those that one was she was a badass at
the age that she was because i remember
they brought her in for questioning this
was in one of the scenes sorry spoiler
but this shit's been out for [ __ ]
like a year now and um
so
they have the lineup right where he's
caught and they have the lineup and all
that type of [ __ ] and they were like
being really nicer because she was
really young like five or six she's like
they're like she's five and five or six
or some [ __ ] she's like okay like you
know just you know you if you see the
guy um just you know kind of write it
down a lot uh and they're like
immediately the little girl was like
okay do you want me to spell number
three or write the number three
like
she was just like a meme she should do
exactly richard ramirez is a very like
unique looking guy bro but there was one
where he killed
he like stomped her this girl's head out
right she was this girl's daughter right
so the daughter was at the um what's it
called the court hearing she's like
she's like you'll never understand how
it feels to sit there and then turn and
see these girls that
want this guy that literally murdered
your mother by stomping her [ __ ] face
in she's like it was the weirdest thing
for me to like you know process yeah
yeah i'm like damn that's [ __ ] crazy
because even when i watch the uh the ted
bundy thing right obviously
nowadays we have so much more access to
information we understand like just the
concept of mental health right it's just
so different now but back then like
they had no idea they didn't know what
the [ __ ] was going on they they'd get
all their news from the tv and that's
all they knew
but like when you see this guy [ __ ]
talk like
i don't like you just know that this
dude is off yeah something is off like
something's not right you know and even
the way he was because
i guess this is one of the first court
cases they filmed from beginning to end
and there was so much that would go on
like the way he would kind of like
[ __ ] on his attorneys and just like
kick get him kicked off his team like he
kept switching attorneys in out getting
rid of them especially when they would
do a good job he was like yo [ __ ] you
you're out of here is this like
self-sabotage like is it documentary
like the actual footage yeah oh it is
confessing
on the tape
because that's what the ted bundy tapes
were yeah he's talking about all the
people you murdered and he kind of like
liked the attention you could tell
because he's like a he's a grade a
narcissist and any time somebody would
give him a compliment or they would say
to him like oh you don't seem like a
murderer like he would like enjoy it
like he he's loving him thank you any
time anytime he can get more attention
to himself he would do it whether it's
kicking off another attorney where he
could uh cross-examine the witness or
whatever he went to crossing them and a
witness that saw him
going into a house but he was like very
professional very like
methodical and and they turned out he
was manic depressive bipolar
and on opposite ends of the spectrum of
his you know episodes he would be very
like cool really relaxed and then the
opposite end he'd be out there murdering
chicks what's crazy is how like back in
the day how long it took or how long you
could get away with that [ __ ] all right
cause like nowadays you could because
like even that killer next door [ __ ]
what set it off for them to get that
chris guy i think it was a couple days
after but he was doing an interview on
the the news
and uh
the lady asked him the newscaster just
decided to ask so did you guys get into
like any arguments or fights before she
left and he goes yeah you know we had a
we were in an argument before um she
left and maybe that's why she left but
immediately after that they bring him in
for questioning right they're like look
you you said that you got in a fight
with your wife before she left now we
have to question you i was like damn bro
that was so quick who was the person
that patton oswald's wife the golden
state killer yeah and that dude silent
so we did jake and he was a silent mic
and we talked about it there and he was
like oh dude i knew the guy
they lived in the same town his i guess
silent mike's
uh
like dad used to coach their kids or
something like that and he was like i've
been in the same room with this
[ __ ] bro and he was like i
remember his face because when he got
arrested the homies showed me the
picture was like yo you remember the
dude he was like [ __ ] yeah i remember
those guys like even though their kids
were like yeah my dad was a [ __ ]
psychopath oh yeah
i don't really know anything about that
he was like it was very similar to
richard ramirez yeah you could you could
watch it on uh i think that on netflix
oh hbo okay it's pretty [ __ ] intense
though but just like what you were
saying um
in like sacramento right yeah sacramento
was originally a farm town like so you
know whatever 30 years ago or so it was
just all these houses were spread apart
so people he was just murdering people
left and right but nobody was doing any
follow-up
it's like it would just happen back they
almost didn't believe that like because
this is at a time where like serial
killers weren't a thing like this wasn't
known like
so
they didn't think that these killings
were connected by any means and one of
the advice that the cops gave or like
the news was giving is like oh he won't
kill you if you're with somebody else
right so there'll be two women together
or something or it'll be like a husband
and a wife together yeah so he's like oh
really you don't think that i'll kill
you if somebody else is there so he
would [ __ ] rape
the the like the guy's wife in front of
them with like a gun to like the back of
her head damn and then he would just
[ __ ] her that's that's what's crazy and
then they talked about that he would put
plates on the husband he would make him
like be in the kitchen put a bunch of
plates on him around him so and on top
of him while he's laying down he's like
if i hear plates move i'm going to blow
your wife's brains out while he would go
rape the wife
in like a different room and then kill
him anyways yeah like he would he would
he would kill him anyways and then he
had a family and children and his
children hated him yeah they're like
he's a [ __ ] sick [ __ ] yeah
and then even with the ted bundy stuff
right like it just shows the advice that
people were getting because this is like
super old-timey this [ __ ] would never
fly today
but they were talking about when you're
getting raped
they're like just let it happen
because what in the hell if you let it
happen then it will kill you they won't
kill you but it's like dude
this is like such old-timey men [ __ ]
right like like for them to be giving
that type of advice just like when they
said smoking cigarettes was okay yeah
and it's literally just a time thing
right yeah but the the ted bundy stuff
to me was so crazy the [ __ ] that this
[ __ ] got away with because when
he was in trial he was only on trial for
two murders
but they didn't know that he was killing
all the way from california and he got
popped in florida but he made his way
all the way across the state killing all
kinds of women the official count is
like 30 something yeah but really people
think that he's killed over a hundred
people a lot of jane doe's people they
have no idea same with the night stalker
yeah so the night stalker actually went
up to norcal and killed a couple people
up there and then came back down but
it's crazy because when you watch a
documentary like you know it was back in
the day right so they didn't have the
technology we had and [ __ ] but it also
showed how like the news outlet in the
media
they were like [ __ ] [ __ ] right
because
they interview one of the ladies right
that was the new one of the news
reporters going on it and the
the the fbi or whatever i forget who is
exactly on it but they had like a
specific piece of evidence and it was a
shoe
he always wore a specific [ __ ] shoe
that wasn't like a normal shoe that
everybody wore right and it was the same
size every single time
and it was like an avila shoe or some
[ __ ] like that but they had this
knowledge and then so like in their head
they're like all right we cannot let
this get out because if he finds out we
know what shoes he's wearing right then
he's going to start changing his [ __ ]
shoes and that's the only thing we have
that's the only lead that they had so
far and for some
some
way one of the news reporters this lady
found out so they were talking with the
police and then she had just so like
kind of threw it in the face oh like
yeah it's because like the shoe that he
wears
and they're like oh my god how the [ __ ]
do you know about that
and then they were like you can't let
that out and they had to come to an
ultimatum of well you got to give us an
interview and we won't say it wow it's
like bro you gotta give your life right
you guys are literally like putting more
lives in jeopardy because you want to do
that [ __ ] but it just [ __ ] killed her
on the spot yeah made it look like an
accident but same with him exactly at
the end of it they're talking about some
murders like jane doe's and [ __ ] that
they never solved that
like after all that kind of had [ __ ]
that almost looked like it was probably
him and they would they found out like
he was going back and forth so there was
probably a lot of unsolved murders that
he did
out there and [ __ ] but they can't
continue that girl's going to hell that
reporter yeah
but it's just like bro like he's going
to hell it's almost like they're like
threatening like oh well yeah you had to
give us an interview so like he's like i
did the interview and like he was kind
of like very just like like you know
short answered stern with it because
like he don't want to do that [ __ ] right
but like that [ __ ] was crazy to to just
even see like bro like people are
getting killed and you're over here
nobody out in these streets dude
anybody who's charming
[ __ ] them dude low-key if you're yeah if
your [ __ ] don't stink bro hey that's why
i stay low-key you guys know me by now
if i don't really know you i didn't get
to know you for six years
i'm quiet until i start to actually like
know you know you cause i'm like people
are weird though like these guys are
very good at opening up and they start
telling you things and i've been finding
out like similar traits of all these
people that i met who have been really
weird and crazy people are people who
meet you once and they start telling you
everything about their life they're too
comfy those people are the ones you have
to worry about they it's actually a sign
of borderline personality disorder like
when you when they come up to you and
they just start opening up their heart
and everything and they try to connect
you by telling you all their deep
darkest secrets yeah that's one of the
biggest things and i have met so many
people like that it's gotten to the
point where i'm just like
bad sign yeah yeah i mean i
like like he said like he was joking but
for real like when me and david first
made each other we didn't talk that much
like i was just like you know i don't
really know david i know that what he
does but i you know i ain't trying to
like talk you know we're not homies yet
you know and that's how i've always been
growing up it's like and i think it's
kind of because of my dad because my
dad's
quiet
and kind of like stern and [ __ ] but he
grew up out here when it was bad in l.a
you know he's salvadorean and he grew up
out here you know at the time with like
ms and [ __ ] like that so you know he
kind of always has been you know you
look straight you do your [ __ ] you don't
stare at people man i can't tell you how
many times if we got caught staring my
dad like what the [ __ ] are you doing
stop [ __ ] staring like we were
getting
father
[ __ ] spaghetti man dude i was like i
love you daddy
no um but like anywhere like if we
stared at someone in public oh if we
point it at somebody god damn my dad
will flip like that [ __ ] used to like
when if you pointed at somebody my
parents used to get [ __ ] up
man that [ __ ] don't happen tomorrow
no but i know people like that dude my
homie aaron aaron does that [ __ ]
sometimes he's one of those people
you're like hey don't turn around and
like right now and stare at them but
like hey look at this person be like who
i'm like bro i literally just said don't
[ __ ] turn social cues are missing
with aaron i'm like [ __ ] yeah they're a
little bit messing with him and then
like another person i know too uh i it's
happened so many times like at the gym
and [ __ ] we're like dude uh like oh
there's that person like who him i'm
like bro why are you pointing i'll kill
you right you might as well walk up and
be like this guy yeah i'm like why are
you pointing like but my dad used to
flip out on us and [ __ ] like that but i
was getting stressed right now he's left
i know but no i mean that's how it is
and when you point at somebody you're
talking that's like mad disrespect yeah
bro but no just like from the back here
and i'll go right down
it's [ __ ] going back to the ted bunny
thing right yeah this [ __ ] is in
court he's giving his final uh statement
and he's talking to the judge and he's
pointing his finger and the judge is
like you better not point that finger at
me you better point that pink finger
somewhere else and he's like
yeah
he's like he just voted and [ __ ] like he
was like
yeah and he put his hand in his pocket
and he stopped real quick though he's
gonna cut that he judged joe mathis yeah
you better not point at me i feel that
though because like people
that are just like
like i'm not saying you can't be
friendly but that are just like way too
friendly like if a [ __ ] i've
never met come to me what do you want
hey what's up starts hugging me and
shooting and i also read the room though
i don't even know you dude you gotta
chill and especially with you right
you're a person of influence when
someone comes at you very hard and is
like oh i want to help you with like i
want to do stuff for you what's your
normal response do you do you can't get
kind of like uh oh you know how it is
you've seen it before hey this is his
response right here that tito hand come
out
i was at a wedding not too long ago and
then um
or somebody getting a little too
friendly with me you know i'm very nice
or whatever but you know we all drinking
or whatever what not right but then
grabbing the inner thighs
[Music]
hey man like i don't
i don't want to drink with you right
because i don't really know him like
that right and plus like
i'm chilling is he a fan yes and i don't
want to get too drunk right so i gotta
oh that's just okay so i like i want to
make sure that i uh i'm still sober or
whatever but just kept coming up to me
over and over and over again and
you know what happened that little smile
came out i was like i started smiling
i'm like what's up and then literally my
friend comes over he goes hey i'm gonna
bring you over
here and he takes the he takes the dude
away a little bit he knows yeah
i'll take the shot with you i'll take
the shot with you right he goes all
right well i'll come back with six more
you gotta smash all these with me he's
like no no i'm gonna take one shot with
you we're gonna take the shot and go
away yeah he's like no just me and you
in a different room
take your pants off
but they were uh he was talking and then
my buddy's super [ __ ] nice and you
just see i just see him in the distance
go like this he goes
like that now he's like cursing him out
yeah then he comes back i was like what
happened because i was gonna [ __ ] that
pull up i see you're not any better than
me dude you bout to do the same [ __ ] i
was gonna do yeah some people are just
too persistent like yeah like for real
no means no yeah dude he was a little
raping yeah like don't be raped
especially with another dude you can't
be if you're a guy and you're you want
to hang out with another guy
if you give any rapey vibes that that's
never going to happen yeah you guys will
never be friends so [ __ ] end it now i
know i just never understood yeah like
just how nick was talking about like
reading the room like
it's weird how some people just can't do
that right and now that you're talking
about the wedding it reminds me so i was
at my boy alfonso's wedding like the
reception and
some one of his family members was
dating this guy at the time they're not
dating anymore so i could say it
whatever
but [ __ ] um like supposedly he did muay
thai or he did it at one point right and
i was already training but i just
remember sitting there and like
knowing the story now like they weren't
really ever close with this guy or
whatever like that but it's alfonso's
wedding and i'm sitting there looking at
him and this guy's just
liter it's like a movie scene this guy's
here talking his ear off and alfonso is
very quiet he's a normal normal quiet
person if you don't know him like he's
very quiet and i just see if i'm going
like looking around he's like
i'm just laughing like hey bro this
like crazy i'm all telling aaron i'm
like dude look at this [ __ ] we were
laughing so hard and then i went up to
get a drink and he's like hey alex hey
alex i look he's like come here real
quick i'm like oh [ __ ] yeah alfonso said
that yeah and he's like he's passing the
bus straight up straight up he goes hey
alex trains muay thai
oh
this was [ __ ] up
and then the guy said oh you do where
you train right and it's like i'm like
just being nice and like say nick is
alphonse all right i'm like yeah and i
look fonzo's gone
hey classic i do that
you know who does that your boy does
that and so i talked to him for a little
bit and then finally i just had to go
like hey bro i gotta um my homies here
by himself too i'm gonna go over there
and chill with him oh for show for show
and i went to oh my boy you just left me
here with this [ __ ] you're just
like and u.s sucks though cause like
part of you
doesn't obviously want to talk to this
guy right actually not part of you like
all of me because i don't know him at
all but then sometimes like i've been
that's a situation too where i just feel
kind of bad because you're like this guy
just
he's just bad at talking to people like
really bad and sometimes you feel bad
but then
he talks to you again and you're like
all right
i give a lot of chances dude it's like
because i'm i'm very good at like ending
conversations precisely and it's not
small hints it's just but it's very
polite yeah i'm like amen it was great
talking to you i have other people i
want to talk to right now but it was
good connect and they just keep going if
somebody hits you with that don't talk
to them again they're like no it's okay
so basically what i was doing
if if somebody leaves a conversation
like that let me go they don't want to
talk to you bro but even if the
conversation has to get to that point
yeah like like i can like i said it's
the the social cues right i can already
start to feel when someone's like done
talking
and i i'll be at that point all right
cool i'll let you get back to your [ __ ]
dude yep i like i feel like i shouldn't
i mean i'm sure it happens and you don't
read it every time but like yeah i feel
weird i would feel weird and feel bad if
i got to a point where i'm talking
someone be like hey man sorry bro i
gotta i gotta go talk to these other
people though like if it got to that
point i'd be like oh [ __ ] i was talking
too too much
but that's really what it is like i'll
let people know it's like well it's a
wedding too because i am gonna talk to
other people yeah so it's like you know
i'm here with friends i'm not gonna
you're a stranger i'm not gonna sit here
for the majority of the wedding that's
it then talk to you if you're if you're
a stranger to you yeah you should know
so and if it happens naturally let it
happen yeah because at no point in time
would you ever if you're having a good
conversation with me that you just met
it'll just flow you know what i mean and
then you guys end up in the room
together years ago like you know you
guys are kissing you're taking your
shots
all of a sudden you guys own a dog
together it's gonna die in 13 years but
it's all good you guys gonna move in
it's all good oh man i found out i'm gay
guys it's my coming out moment just
about the love of your life and that's
fine peanut butter it doesn't happen
that way you can't force it yeah you
can't yeah it's just like like even with
this wedding like talking to this dude i
was very straightforward it's like hey i
got to stay sober i drove here so i
don't want to drink it's like let's
let's kill it oh can i buy you more
shots well let me buy come on it was it
was literally i [ __ ] you not probably
over 10 or 12 times that's way too i
hate them i hate i'll buy you another
shot [ __ ] so 10 or 12 times very
generous i was very stern too and it
gets to the point where i'm smiling
somebody's getting sucked there's like i
said no i don't want a [ __ ] shot
like literally queue one of my buddies
like oh [ __ ] i just started like speed
walking towards me he goes hey we gotta
bring you away when i'm in that
situation someone's like oh yo like let
me buy you a drink i'm like i actually
don't drink but alex will drink with you
and that's what i'll do and that's why
you're a terrible i don't even and he no
i don't drink either so yeah that's why
it's funny because the guy will go up to
alex and be like oh let me buy you a
drink and then alex will be like oh i
don't drink and then that guy looks
moted you just got to go to therapy
motions do you want to buy me a drink
because you're looking for companionship
what happened to her be like just be
like why
and he goes why that's too real
and he walks away and cries well guys
that wraps up this episode of the genius
brave podcast it'll be annoying okay
don't be annoying yeah man i'll fill out
conversations love your dogs because you
don't have them for that specifically
nick dude he doesn't have any time left
with his dog
hey you know what everybody everybody
messes nick with just good heartfelt
messages yeah man seven blessings dude
you could catch nick
he's fine all right he's good
alex i beat all your asses bro i'm
telling you
got this month even bro that's lift god
with three f's you can see them at their
own podcast that we out here mma where
they talk about fighting and scrapping
and diddly dabbling diddly dab mostly
diddly daddling
pizza knit pepperoni
when did you get gilbert on oh we're
gonna we gotta do that soon actually
yeah before he gets too famous for those
nipples